What are the least invasive ways to monitor your cancer?
So of course you're a collegeist if you still have a relationship with your collegeist is going to want to do scans
And while I love scans because you can see the most with them. They're not
not invasive. So
Pat scan is going to be radiation a CT scan is going to be radiation at MRI is typically going to
You know, you got the magnetic field that can best with your body, plus you're going to have gadolinium as a dye.
So short of doing those things, what are some other ways to look at it? Some people look at circulating tumor cells or cancer stem cells or some lab that does that.
Or you could look at
on
Do looking at running tumor markers. I think I just spoke to somebody this morning or maybe sometime this week about they've never run tumor marker tests. They've never heard of tumor marker tests. Go to our blog and
Dissearch tumor marker. You'll see it pops up. But I give you a whole display of different tumor marker tests that one can run for any particular cancer.
So that's a way to monitor your cancer. And then also just looking at standard blood work. Comprehensive metabolic panel and give us clues. All tests are just giving us clues. So
These are objective things that we're talking about here first. So comprehensive metabolic panel. You look at your liver marker. You've got liver markers. You're looking all the markers and if they're out of balance, they can tell us and give us clues of things that are going on
And then a complete blood cow to CBC. It's another standard blood test. Get one with a differential so that you can get a breakdown of the white blood cells. And you can see, of course, it has anemia. Anemia is very common with cancer.
So if you have an anemia that can help monitor the cancer is stable or getting worse or whatever.
So that's another way inexpensive and least invasive ways to monitor your cancer. And then from a subjective standpoint, how are you feeling or do you have fatigue? Do you have, you know, you go through
different subjective things. If you have a cancer that's palpable, like an abreast cancer, you feel like it's getting worse or bigger.
There's the things that you want to judge in this process. And then you put them all together. So you don't just look at one thing. You look at all of them together to see.
Give you clues on whether you're moving to the right direction or the wrong direction.